if you are a female and have certain
problems with your reproductive organs
your doctor may recommend a robotic
hysterectomy to remove your uterus
your reproductive organs include your
vagina
cervix
uterus
fallopian tubes
and ovaries
you may need a robotic hysterectomy if
you have one of the following diseases
or conditions heavy or constant uterine
bleeding anemia and pelvic pain cancer
in your uterus
cervix
or ovaries
non-cancerous fibroid tumors in your
uterus
or slipping and sagging of your uterus
into your vagina due to weak or injured
pelvic muscles and uterine ligaments
before your procedure an intravenous
line or IV will be started you may be
given antibiotics through the IV to
decrease your chance of infection
you'll be given general anesthesia a
breathing tube will be inserted through
your mouth and down your throat to help
you breathe during the operation
your surgeon will make a small incision
near your belly button and insert a
plastic tube called a port carbon
dioxide gas will be pumped into your
abdomen through this port the gas will
inflate your abdomen giving your surgeon
more room to see and move the surgical
tools
after your abdomen is inflated a
high-definition camera will be inserted
into this port
your surgeon will make additional port
incisions for robotic instruments as
well as instruments used by patients I'd
assistance
an assistant will insert all of the
robotic tools through these ports unlike
standard laparoscopic instruments these
tools can rotate 360 degrees and have
more flexibility than the human wrist
seated at a special console your surgeon
will operate the robotic arms and the
camera with joystick like controls and
foot pedals
a computer will translate the exact
movements of your surgeon's fingers into
precise movements of the surgical tools
same time a high-definition vision
system will provide a magnified
three-dimensional stereoscopic view of
the surgical area
depending on your condition you may have
a partial hysterectomy in which your
surgeon will remove your uterus
but leave your cervix fallopian tubes
and ovaries in place
if you have a total hysterectomy your
surgeon will remove your cervix along
with your uterus
if you have a radical hysterectomy your
surgeon may also remove your fallopian
tubes ovaries
the upper part of your vagina
as well as nearby tissue such as your
pelvic lymph nodes
at the end of your procedure the tiny
incisions will be closed with stitches
staples surgical glue or closure tape
dressings
after your procedure your breathing tube
will be removed and you will be taken to
the recovery area for monitoring you
will be given pain medication as needed
you may continue to receive antibiotics
through your IV you may be released from
the hospital the same day or within one
day after the procedure